[Music]  James Franco gifted co-star Bryan  Cranston with marijuana sort of and it's  a really good guy and his heart is  always in the right place  he ain't it the why him actors stopped  by Conan O'Brien's show on Wednesday and  Brian hilariously revealed James gave  him cannabis in the form of art James  isn't this right you gave you gave Brian  a a painting as a gift yeah and what was  it it was a beautiful painting of a  marijuana leaf I think we have it I  think we have this painting there it is  a president brian says his wife Robyn  Deardon wasn't too fond of we have a  nice little Connecticut home and I said  honey where do you think this would fit  and she said I don't know if it would  fit anywhere over the bed over the bed  he actually painted it with real  marijuana leaf in in the painting and so  that's why so it got held up at customs  the drug dogs are  [Music]